ich bin von London bis nach Istanbul nur
mit dem Zug gefahren und wir befinden
uns gerade schon in Budapest wo ich dann
nämlich am Mittwoch zwei Tage nachdem
ich am Montag in London losgefahren bin
morgens aufgewacht bin das coole war
mein Kollege Louis kam dazu der hat mich
in Budapest besucht und wir haben dann
die Reise von Budapest bis nach Istanbul
weiter zusammen angetreten abends sind
wir in Budapest in einen Schlafabteil
das beste Schlafabteil im CFR Nachtflug
gestiegen und sind dann 16 Stunden von
Budapest bis nach Bukarest gereist wo
wir dann am Donnerstag gegen Mittag
angekommen sind wir wollten Bukarest auf
die Stadt sehen deswegen haben wir uns
da Hotel genommen und haben eine Nacht
in Bukarest verbracht Ticket für den
weiteren Zug bis nach Istanbul konnte
man nicht im Internet buchen und mir
wurde gesagt ich muss es dort im Buch
heißt am Schalter kaufen leider gab sie
Direktverbindung zu der zeitlich und wir
mussten dann schauen wir weiterkommen
wir haben uns leider dafür nicht den
schlaustenweg entschieden und sind dann
am Freitag weitergefahren Richtung
gestrandet und haben nicht mehr weiter
haben uns dazu entschieden die
restlichen 400 km zu fliegen weil sonst
werden wir gar nicht mehr angekommen
eine Alternative wäre gegebenenfalls
noch über die bulgarische gewesen aber
ja wir haben Zeit ein bisschen absolutes
Abenteuer und wir sind am Ende